we are very excited about our next guest
it's comedian Jordan klepper the latest
guest host of The Daily Show that'll be
starting tonight you know clever from
two decades of Comedy including as a
contributor on The Daily Show both with
Jon Stewart and then with Trevor Noah
his field pieces have been viewed more
than 100 million times and that's what
you get with interviews with vaccine
Skeptics and insurrectionists I like a
big range of people and recently klepper
spoke with supporters of former
president Donald Trump who were outside
the New York courthouse where Donald
Trump was arraigned take a look in a
listen
while I had fun getting into the scrum I
was surprised to find there were people
who wanted to have meaningful
conversations about the justice system I
don't believe we're what we're seeing
what you're seeing is Justice you don't
believe in the grand jury process I
don't believe if if this was a civilian
it would I mean he is a civilian he's a
person but New York address so he
shouldn't go through the grand jury
process
I believe it should be
[Music]
because because
um I
I'm going by General gut feeling
you can see the look on his face yeah he
realized I don't really have a reason
yes I just like that of feeling I no
longer want to answer this question yeah
I mean we have a legal system in place
but Bill's gut seemed as good as
anything he's got a feeling here or
maybe somewhere else on the body is
where that feelings come from uh okay
The Daily Show uh or uh Jordan clever
joins us now I didn't give you the
proper introduction so I wanted to thank
you I looked into the camera Jordan
Clepper of The Daily Show as a host now
this week I can give you notes uh always
find your camera you've got to find one
cameras the words are there this is oh I
know and if the prompter goes out I mean
because the state of nature really
quickly flip the table we're making fire
uh I'm sorry we have you in this chair
and now that you're an anchor and not at
the anchor desk over there yeah frankly
people see my legs makes me
uncomfortable yeah
so what did you learn if anything about
the opinions on the Trump arraignment
that you found outside the courthouse
and did you see crying people Donald
Trump said he saw police officers and
people that were crying and apologizing
did you see any of that I I saw very few
weeping people outside the Trump
indictment I saw a ton of media what I
learned I don't I don't go to Trump
events looking to learn uh rarely
there's a lot of Education being given
out the indictment what you did see is a
media circus uh just Amplified by a few
Maga faithful who were not going to be
at all thwarted by any information about
this upcoming trial and then folks like
Marjorie Taylor green and George Santos
coming in to try to get some of that
shine George Santos was there you asked
him uh about where he went to law school
Stanford Harvard that was really great
and then the volleyball Legacy yeah any
answers on that you know he's still
quiet about it I think America this is
why you send a comedian into the field
as there's questions Americans have
about our volleyball history as a nation
it's not in books and so if Santos won't
answer these questions how else are we
supposed to know so Santos has not
announced that he's running for
president but other people have they're
going to challenge Donald Trump uh how
do you feel about the Republican field I
don't see anybody who's actually
offering a different point of view
outside of Donald Trump uh the Santa
seems to want to run alongside him and I
think when I talk to folks in the Maga
Universe there's interest in DeSantis
but nobody's letting go uh their big red
hat yet and I think until somebody grows
enough of a backbone to say I'm not him
I'm me but he seems to be the choice
well listen Donald Trump's core base is
still extremely strong despite the fact
that he's been indicted and other cases
are waiting in the wings and now we're
all looking at the Dominion case this
week do you think that there's anything
that will come out of that case that
could change their minds how do you
think they're looking at that particular
trial I mean frankly I think where
they're going to go for their news
they're not going to hear about this
case uh Fox isn't going to talk about it
I don't think Newsmax or oan is going to
make that center stage and yet they've
sort of been conditioned to take any
information that's not pleasing to their
worldview as something to dismiss it
completely so your guest hosting this
week you are well known for those field
pieces I wonder what kind of field
pieces we can expect this week and kind
of guess because what's been interesting
is each guest host has had an
interesting perspective on the kind of
guess that they want to talk to on the
show and want to put their own spinner
that's right yeah yeah I mean I love
going out into the field and I wanted to
bring field elements into the show this
week I went to the world's largest gun
show in Tulsa to talk about American Gun
culture so you're going to see me there
I went and talked to AO not any gun CEOs
Tony and I have been talking about this
were there any people who actually are
CEOs or gun manufacturers there at this
gun show event they do not want to talk
to me for some reason I figured gun CEOs
don't return my text messages uh but gun
owners tend to talk to me in a parking
lot and I got to see The Gun Show
loophole happen in real time people
bring out money they're in a parking lot
they show a gun and they exchange hands
so that was sort of mind-blowing for me
to see that up close I'm also going to
talk to Gretchen Whitmer AOC I kind of
went out into the world I want to bring
kind of important conversations to this
week why do you want this job does your
mom want you to get it most
ly for their kids but does she want you
to get it my mom is the best we're from
Kalamazoo Michigan and she says drop
that Midwest nice and tell them what you
want I would love this job I've been a
fan of The Daily Show since I was a
little kid uh Jon Stewart started 47
years ago and so I've been watching ever
since and a chance to sit behind the
desk uh work with such great talented
folks uh I look forward to a great would
you change it up would you want to
change it up would it change the show up
yeah I totally changed it up I think
late night is constantly evolving I
think you have to bring in new voices
whether they're sitting next to you or
you're talking to them you also have to
go out into the world the benefit that I
have as I talk to Real Americans I see
those experiences and I think we covered
news in real time we're the only late
night show when the indictment happened
that had somebody who was there that day
yes yes I hope you can remain friends
with all of your former colleagues who
are also trying out for this job that's
right we those tensions have been frayed
for years
they're not coming back
Jordan clever thank you very much nice
that's what Mom said you can watch
Jordan guest hosting the Daily Show uh
tonight on Comedy Central Time time what
time it 10 p.m 11 11